الاعلام الاسرائيلي كشف مؤخرا عن مناورات
جويه مشتركه بين القوات الجويه
الاسرائيليه والامريكيه هذه المناورات
حاكه هجوما على منشات ايران اناويه كذلك
سبقتها مناورات وجاءت ضمن السلسله تحركات
عسكريه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه شملت
ارسال سلاح الجو الامريكي لقاذفات ب 52 في
مهام تدريبيه لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وكذلك
ايضا سبقت هذه المناورات مناورات
اسرائيليه تحاكي حربا مع ايران وكذلك
مليشيتها في المنطقه على الجانب الاخر
ايران تستمر في تطوير برنامجا اناوي لكن
هل نحن امام تدريبات روتينيه ام استعدادات
ميدانيه لخطوات وتحركات عسكريه والى اي
مضى اصلا واشنطن مقتنعه بجهه النظر
الاسرائيليه بضروره توجيه ضربه عسكريه الى
منشات طيران
بهجت بروفيسور دراسات الامن الوطني في
كليه الدفاع الوطني معنا من واشنطن اولا
بروفيسور بهجت اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتاريا
هل نحن امام مناورات روتينيه ام اننا امام
تحركات عسكريه جديه من قبل تل ابيب واشنطن
تحاكي ضربه فعليه في المستقبل لمنشات
ايران نوويه
لمعرفه الجواب وفقا للمصادر المفتوحه ما
نعرفه ان هناك حرب معلوماتنا وحرب نفسيه
بين امريكا وايران
يحاولون من خلالها كل طرف التاثير على
سياسات الطرف الاخر وباعث رسائل مختلفه
اما فيما يخص مستقيه التقارير حول زياده
التعاوني بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
من وجهه نظري للولايات المتحده تحاول
ارسال الرسائل الى ايران مفادها اننا
عندما نقول ان الخيار العسكري متاح على
الطاوله فنحن نعني ما نقولها ولا يمكن ان
نستبعد عمليات عسكريه اسرائيليه مدعومه من
قبل الولايات المتحده اما ان كانت هذه
التقرير موثوقه فلا احد يعرف يفترض انا
ايران حالها اي دوله لديها استخباراتها
الخاصه وسيكتشفون بانفسهم اذا ما كانت هذه
التقارير موثوقه ام لا اف دي اس ريبورس ار
كريدبلوررناوت
دكتور جوده يعني هناك اختلاف ما بين
واشنطن وتل ابيب في تقييم التهديد الامني
الذي تشكله ايران لكن على مستوى العسكريين
برايك هل تعتقد بان العسكريين في واشنطن
يقتنعون بوجهه النظر الاسرائيليه بحتميه
توجيه ضربه اا عسكريا لمنشاتنا ايران
نوويه
لانه من وجهه نظر امريكا لا توجد معلومات
استخباراتيه كامله وفي امريكا ناخذ
التقارير الاسرائيليه حول البرنامج النووي
الايراني
وقدراتها النوويه ضمن السياق ان اسرائيل
لديها لمصلحه في اقناع الولايات المتحده
للقيام بعملنا عسكري ضد ايران الولايات
المتحده لا ترغب في شن حرب ايران او اي
دوله اخرى ونحن لدينا معلوماتنا
الاستخباراتيه وندرك ان اسرائيل ربما
واركز على كلمه ربما تبالغ في تقييم تهديد
الايراني لكننا ندرك انا اسرائيل لديها
مصالحها الخاصه ولا نعتبر كل ما تقوله
اسرائيل حقائق
الان ومع التقارير التي تتحدث عنها
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه عن رفع
ايران لمستوى تخصيب اليورانيوم هل فات
الاوان على منع ااا ايران من امتلاك سلاح
نووي
بيزون
وفقا للمصادر المفتوحه لم يفوت الاوانه
قبل نحو سته او سبعه اشهر هنا قال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي الاسبق يهود بركه
صناعه القنبله وحسب معلوماتي فان ايران
ليس بوسعها صناعه القنبله حتى الان وقبل
شهر قال مستشار ايه الله خامنئي انهم
وصلوا مرحله صناعه القنبله اذا ما قرروا
ذلك وكما قلت فان اسرائيل لديها المصلحه
في المبالغه بالتهديد الايراني وفي نفس
الوقت غير على لديها المصلحه في المبالغه
بقدرتها وقد حاول المسؤولون الايرانيون
بعث رساله الى الولايات المتحده مفادها
انه فات الاوان ونستطيع الصناعه القنبله
لا احد يعرف بالضبط لان المعلومات السريه
ولسنا متاكدين مما يجري داخل ايران لكن
بيحسب المصادر المفتوحه اعتقد ان ايران
لديها ما يكفي الان لكن امر سيستغرق بعد
الوقت لتسليح اليورانيوم المخصب الذي
بحوزتها الشيء الذي اعرفه والعالم متاكد
منه هو انا ايران اليوم ليس لديها القنبله
ايران داز نوت هيلز ذا بوم
دكتور جوده فيما يتعلق بوجهه النظر
الايراني هل تعتقد بانه النظام الايراني
ياخذ هذه التهديدات الخارجه من تل ابيب
على محمل الجد
ووو ولكن كل الدول تاخذوا تهديدات على
محمل الجد واسرائيل سبق ان هجمت ايران من
الداخل بالاضافه الى الاهداف الايرانيه في
لبنان وسوريا والعراق فلو كنت في الحكومه
الايرانيه او مسؤولا ايرانيه بلا شك اخذ
تهديدات الاسرائيليه على محمل جدا اسرائيل
لديها قدرته ورغته في مهاجمه ايران
فالاجابه بلا شك نعم نعم
الدكتور جوده يعني لاحظنا مؤخرا بانه
ايران بتحاول ان يعني تظهر انها قوه
عسكريه كبيره لكن على الجانب الاخر اذا
قامت اسرائيل بتوجيه هكذا ضربه الى منشات
ايران النوويه برايك كيف ستتعامل ايران هل
سترد بشكل مباشر ام انها ستلجا الى اشعال
حرب اقليميه عبر ميليشياتها في المنطقه
اخر ما اعرفهم فتره طويله ان المشكله
النوويه في ايران اصبحت مساله امن قومي
ومساله فخر ايضا ولا استطيع ان اتخيل
ايران لا ترد على هجوم اسرائيلي ما احاول
ان اقوله هو انه اذا ما هجمت اسرائيل
ودمرت المنشات النوويه الايرانيه كما فعلت
في سوريا والعراق فقدت ايران لن يكون
لديهم خيار سوى الرد عبر الانتقام لانهم
ان لم يفعلوا سيبدون ضعفاء جدا في اعين
شعبهم ولهذا السبب اعتقد ان الرد الايراني
سيشمل حربا اقليميه لذلك اعتقد ان اسرائيل
الى ما هجمت المنشات النوويه سوف تتسبب في
اندلاع حرب هنا اقليميه في المنطقه
[موسيقى]